[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you know cope I'm just leaving the
Williams house now
Jennifer's out in Emma's asleep I'll
leave the keys for you with Alex at the
care center before I head to the airport
no I I need to go home
I know I made a longer commitment but I
need to get back to my family I can't
explain it it's like something I just
need to get back to the States
Yoko Yoko
Yucko
[Music]
hey welcome home
ah so good to be home
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey what's going on come on we gotta go
we gotta go now
stop playing with that daddy never
finished it
I miss daddy
so much
it's okay cuz we're supposed to you know
I think that's most gonna be really good
for us it's gonna be no place and a new
start nothing Bad's gonna happen to me
okay
nothing Bad's gonna happen to you either
I promise and it means more cuz I'm a
police officer
come on I know first things are hard but
you just got to do it like ripping off a
band-aid
I'm scared to
what are we doing are scared close your
eyes count to five
[Music]
one two three
everything's okay let's go to school
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I heard stuck here with a new chick
don't call them attacks buddy I might
advise that her old man died of cancer
real brutal kid was alone with him when
he died it's only been three months
[Music]
I don't yeah
smoke no I quit
mind if I do
are you liking it around here
we're still getting settled in
it's definitely different
something like this even happen char's
been here for months
doors were locked when we found it
Rossum huh I'll say about an ID yet sure
do
Lorna moody 65 why did it take so long
with finer well this here's the service
room they only just started using it for
the season anyone come looking for her
that's just the feds they're already
looking for
turns out she's one of those assisted
suicide broads find anything on her
usual stuff guy got an address though
directions in the glove box 44 Rae brand
Drive
same places the Landers case looks like
we got another one what
I was the Lando's case
anything else forensics will be here
soon the FBI is on its way to
sure it looks like something was in
there with her
I mean you ever seen anything like this
one detective what's up with the
language house what the K is there two
years ago
sort of start with me it's just French
to see a pop up again maybe they're
connected
it's just a weird concepts
[Music]